i guess i am live so
welcome to another session of these uh
workouts or study with me or however you
want to call it where i share with you
some of the things that i do to learn
languages and some of my thoughts about
language learning
and i welcome you to
ask me questions or make comments or
share your own experience and you can do
it in whatever language is convenient
for you
i will wait till i'll kind of give you
my thoughts of the day and share with
you what i'm doing
and then with 10 or 15 minutes to go
we'll just let that ring
then you can i'll try to answer the
questions that you can start submitting
right now
so
i had this thought
come on
i had this thought
while uh
having my online
session with my farsi tutor on thursday
and uh she's a very good tutor because
she doesn't correct me
she sends me a detailed report of all
the words that i struggled with the
phrases that i struggled with
and mostly she puts me at ease i don't
have to think about what to speak
she asks me questions and then when i
struggle for words she provides them for
me and farsi and the whole thing is a
very enjoyable experience
because i don't expect perfection
i don't worry about the mistakes that i
make i just let the language come out
sometimes i think i'm doing better
sometimes i think i'm not doing as well
as i did before none of that really
matters
because i think in language learning i
thought to myself we have to be able to
deal with
you know less than perfection problems
that's part of the problem with all the
testing that goes on in schools it's as
if we learn for a test so if the goal is
to do well in the test and then you make
mistakes then of course you're defeated
if the goal is to simply expose yourself
to the language in the knowledge that
that is having a beneficial effect it's
making your ability in the language your
knowledge of the language your sense of
the language better and better all the
time
how far you take that is up to you
but this this sort of
expectation of perfection that i i can't
make mistakes or that the teacher
expects me to perform
all of that i find is
is negative
not because and when we are under
pressure we do less well there's no
question where the more relaxed we are
the better we're going to speak when
we're under pressure we can't remember
anything
and life of course is full of
imperfection language learning is is a
world of imperfection a world of making
mistakes and forgetting and not being
able to say things
and this applies to some of the some of
the tools we use
um sometimes i get comments oh google
translate is no good google translate is
google translate it's better than not
having google translate you still have
to think on your own
and there are some languages
notably korean where google translate
doesn't do very well so i didn't find it
as helpful but then none of the
dictionaries are helpful in korean even
the korean dictionaries like naver a lot
of the time doesn't
return a meaning that's relevant to
the text that i'm reading and that's
just life you have to accept it it's
better than having nothing
so similarly now in in my
persian
the dictionaries are not very good
perhaps the best dictionary is google
translate and since google translate is
often not that good
um you know it's a problem but it's
better than having nothing and
with from the incomplete dictionaries
that we have i am still
proceeding
with my
persian i got comments that the text to
speech in arabic is very poor and you
know you should be careful it doesn't
matter it's better than nothing and i
have the human voice to listen to so i
think there's so many situations where
you know our environment for language
learning is so much better than it ever
was all of these tools are so much more
powerful than anything i had 50 years
ago so
it's best not to focus on the shortcut
comings but to take advantage of what's
there you still have to think on your
own
uh you still have to evaluate so you
know at link for example some of the
user hints are not correct because for
whatever reason somebody chose
uh a dictionary definition that wasn't
correct and other people came along and
automatically selected it
and at link that pushes you know that
user hint up to the front we are trying
to eliminate those but it's extr in
languages where there are a lot of user
hints i find it tremendously useful to
see that some you know 10 15 20 people
chose this and it pops up right away and
i use it so i think in life we have to
accept things the way they are
and take advantage of them as best as we
can and it's whenever people ask
perfection or expect for perfection that
they run into problems uh so
and and before moving on i'm going to
show you how i import content but when i
was thinking about this you know we have
to accept less than perfection and make
do in life and that reminded me of the
the seven habits of highly effective
people and i did a series of videos on
this once but it's worth looking at
again and just seeing how much they
apply to language learning so the first
uh
habit that this is stephen covey's
famous book he says be oh i gotta share
the screen hold it hold it hold it you
see i kind of get
caught up in what i'm doing and then i
forget so i'm going to show you these
so here we go share the screen
all right
to present to everyone i guess that
should be good
present to everyone i guess that's
happening so
the seven habits this is stephen covey
you can google him very famous book
um seven habits of successful people now
all of these self-help books one way or
another
repackage
uh
essential common sense so there's
nothing but to the extent that people
are able to write these in ways that
capture people's imagination
they're able to sell a lot of books
still this is this is i think he makes
valid points here number one habit is
habit one be proactive that's so
important in life
the only way you're going to succeed is
if a lot of opportunities come your way
and the only way opportunities are going
to come your way is you if you are
proactive and go out and do things and
make these opportunities come at you uh
so it's a school of life be proactive in
your language learning be proactive in
life
to begin with the end in mind
this is one of
one of his habits that i think is it's
not always applicable because we don't
often know where we're going to go
but we just have to do something
so even in language learning yeah i
would like to get better
but
you know and maybe i can have as a goal
that i want to be
native speaker like but you're not
likely to achieve that so i think it's
important simply to be motivated to
improve i think that's a good enough
goal
rather than saying you know i must
achieve xyz
uh next habit is put first things first
and i take that to mean you know
prioritize so you know you've got to
decide how you're going to spend your
time which is the most valuable way to
spend your time
personally for example i don't find it
useful to sit in front of a movie that i
don't understand let's say in turkish i
was my wife and i were briefly watching
this rather silly turkish
serial on netflix but i could i could
spend hours and hours and hours watching
a turkish
uh
movie or cereal
and i'm not going to pick up i might
pick up one word if i'm really lucky and
i'll probably guess it wrong anyway so
far better to spend time usefully when i
go to learn turkish i'm going to do it
at link and i'm going to be able to read
whatever i listen to and look up words
and do things in a in a proper way
think win-win of course this is so
important in life unless you hold all
the cards where you can dictate things
to people you've got to be
sort of
win-win oriented
and i think in the case of of language
learning you know do things that make
you feel good do things that
don't make you feel as if you lost
so give yourself credit for what you've
done and recognize that you're doing
better than you were before
first to understand of course then be
understood of course i'm a big believer
in input the language has to come from
other people you don't have it within
you and so don't spend so much time
trying to talk when you have a very
limited vocabulary rather bring the
language into you
and you know habit number six synergize
of course this is this whole idea of
using so many different
tools you know listening on your mp3
player reading
uh if you're you know good enough
watching videos in other words talking
writing do all the different
habits and then of course the final
habit he had was and it's here somewhere
uh
renewal and continual improvement yeah
so you've got to stay with it so a brief
digression here
but uh just to say that a lot of these
sort of habits that at least according
to stephen covey we need to be
successful they apply to language
learning not only that we discover so
much so in my persian learning here
there's different
in you know articles that i've read
about iran about the language about the
persian gulf i have already forgotten
who amir khabib was
but i will go back and you know he talks
about renewing and i'll go back there
and study this again and then i'll
remember persepolis cyrus the great
celebrations music because art pros and
poetry and i'm up to 53 i haven't done
this yet but i have downloaded
50 uh up to 53 of these articles from
this website and now i will show you how
i import
so i go over to persian online and if
you're studying persian this is a great
resource
in every language again talking about
being proactive in every language i have
been able to find
resources for czech for romanian for
greek you name it and i do it by
googling uh googling either in the
target language or in english
and so very often people come and say
where can i find resources for xyz
well sometimes they say that without
even telling me what language they're
looking for
um
i mean you have to be a bit of a
self-starter you have to be proactive
start looking and does that make sense
if you say okay i'm learning greek
i have these resources but i'm looking
for more resources so at least you're
sharing those resources that you have
been able to find with other people
we have to be proactive in trying to
find
good content now so i am now up to the
intermediate level they're here at this
persian uh online boy i wish they had
this for arabic at any rate persian
online they have a beginner group
and what they call elementary which is
starting again you know it has tidying
up your room and
going to a restaurant and stuff and then
the what they call intermediate has some
interesting um articles on
uh things related to
um you know persian culture and history
and stuff so i have downloaded up to
number 53 so i'm going to download the
next one which is 54.
so we open this up
and what they offer you
is
a video which i usually ignore
then they have the persian text
and what i do is i take this persian
text and i right click on here
save link as
all right so this saves this audio
to my computer i click save it's gone to
my desktop
now i i never i could stream it here but
i simply don't
and then
here is the text all right
wow this is a great long one poof my
goodness i don't know what the hell this
is
but
because you know
i'm gonna save it all like this okay so
i save it all down about here
and you have to be a little careful that
you don't pick up
extraneous stuff that's on the website
so i try to make sure sometimes i still
get it then i
right click copy
then i go to my
uh here i am okay
so
because i already have a course
so normally to import i would say i can
i can also do it this way i can import
the lesson so i get two ways i can do it
i can either e open one of these and
then go to edit the lesson so i'll show
you that first let's say open this
lesson here
and um
okay so the lesson opens up
and i can go in here so i can view the
course i can add it to a playlist
uh
blah blah blah but here i can edit i can
print it
uh
but i can edit it so when i click on
edit
i am now into the sort of import lesson
area
and i can see that i have
downloaded all of these so here i could
add a new lesson
now i'll just go over here and show you
if i don't do it that way
this is in arabic let's go to farsi
there we are farsi
i could also go import lesson we'll just
let it ring
import lesson
and then i have to
choose persian online three
okay and then i would import there so it
really doesn't matter where i do it so
let's do it here since i'm here so then
i still have my saved text
so i i
paste it here
okay and this is number 53 so i go
uh i believe it was 53 what was it no
it's 54.
there we go 54. okay
54.
now
because this is strictly for my own use
it doesn't matter what i put as the
title i'm not allowed to share these
because we don't have permission
so i sometimes just put this in english
it's just a matter of being able to
recognize
okay now here i have upload
audio file so i click on upload audio
file
and i go to my desktop
and here i have it 54. so i double click
on it
and that is now uploaded
as an audio file
then i go and i save it
then go
so this now saves
and i now have this lesson
it takes a little while sometimes it's
okay with the sound file so now you see
that this persian online course
has gone up to number 54. i'll normally
do
sort of five at a time you know this is
where i say okay this morning i'm going
to invest in getting some more content
into my
system
uh so
if i go to my lessons now
and uh
persian online and i open purge this
course here version online three
uh
lo and behold halftime is there
and if i open it and it says there are
36 blue words all of these new ones that
i haven't done yet they have a lot of
new words like 35
is tough
uh
this one here is 20 but i've started on
it so
these are going to be more difficult
more difficult for me 28
i'm now sort of leaving the area of easy
content such as my uh mini stories and
stuff where a lot of the vocabulary
repeats and it's the more common uh you
know verbs i'm now getting into stuff
where
a
uh it's more difficult vocabulary and b
there's probably a portion of those uh
you know blue words are going to be
names names of poets names of writers
names of places which i won't claim
credit for as known words i'll have to
ignore them but that does
at least at this point bump up
the uh the number of blue words
and of course they also have a lot of
words yellow words links that i'm in
the process of learning so i will be
seeing 120 100
or so 80 words that i have already met
and i'm trying to learn
so and that's kind of where i you know
and and so and i like to if i go back to
my lessons as i've said before
i like to vary it between i still do the
mini stories i was listening to them
this morning because i still get things
words vocabulary that i've forgotten
um i vary the difficulty level all over
the place okay
um
i think that's it now if anybody wants
to ask a question
uh about any aspect of what i've
demonstrated here please
do so and in fact i'm going to have a
look here
on my
ipad just to see if there are any
questions that i can answer right away
here
so let's have a quick look here
are you going to visit japan at some
point i'm going to be in japan oh eric
roberts that wasn't for me but i'm going
to be in japan in october
good morning edwin finch blah blah blah
i have a unit and if what
and you know i don't think i would be
really isn't it thanks so mark chavez
thanks me for my videos and for link i
appreciate your support i love link i'd
love to hear it
now good morning
uh from uh abdul
i mean i want to learn english blah blah
blah please talk more about link goals
the company and all okay uh link goes uh
the company okay
um
i mean
mark and i my son mark and i we
have committed a tremendous amount of
time energy money
into link
because
you know obviously i love language
learning uh it's something i did at the
end of my
career in the lumber business
uh
i just see
so much opportunity for people to
learn languages people around me
who come up to me and say geez i'd like
to learn spanish i like to learn this
and people don't so
i mean it gives me great satisfaction a
to learn languages on my own and b
to see other people succeeding with link
but by the same token link also has to
succeed
so
we are constantly tweaking and trying to
find ways that can generate more traffic
uh make it easier for people to
understand
i mean our goal is to slowly slowly
slowly increase our membership
uh in order that uh you know link can
succeed and
slowly slowly we are succeeding at that
goal so we don't have anything beyond
that we're not going to be the next
i don't know
whatever duolingo but we just want to
gradually uh succeed i think that's
about all i can say
now question i have a problem with
create sentence on my own i'm not sure
is it correct order it what do you
recommend me to okay so obviously this
is this whole question of getting to
output this is from marcin
uh
um
yeah we are
i mean
i have found that we just have to create
these sentences we just have to speak
with whatever we have been able to
create in terms of language habits in
our own mind we have to let that out
without worrying without second guessing
and
most of the mistakes
we will correct ourselves with enough
input and output
it's like children children don't some
people sometimes say well you need to
correct because look
mothers correct correct their children's
english or whatever polish and therefore
the children end up speaking correctly
that's not true the amount of correcting
that the mother or the parents or even
the teachers can do is very limited
people learn from their peers
otherwise
children of immigrants say in canada
would never learn to speak english
properly children of immigrants end up
speaking like their friends and like the
people they meet in life they don't end
up speaking like their parents so that
the it's it's more a process of auto
correction you the more comfortable you
become the more you hear the language
use the language sp read the language
gradually the better you become if you
want to improve now some people don't
want to improve but if you are concerned
about improving then you should just put
more effort into your activities rather
than
worrying about the inability you have
this i get back to what i was saying
earlier about win-win give yourself
credit for what you're able to do
rely on the fact that it will gradually
get better and don't worry about your
mistakes when i speak to my tutors i
don't worry about my mistakes i'm happy
to make them
and i'm happy to engage and i realize
that six months ago i couldn't put two
words together in persian let's say and
now i struggle but i can speak
okay longman dictionary for which
language uh
so we're happy to add dictionaries at
length that we are able to connect to
and uh
if you have a say if it's a you know
polish english english polish or
whatever it might be the best place to
recommend a dictionary is on our forum
but uh we're happy to do that uh i'm
lose focus when listening to my target
language how do you improve your ability
to focus okay but first of all most of
my listening is while doing other tasks
so
i i i think if i just sat down to listen
i would lose focus but if i am doing
something else you know i accept the
fact again it's accepting less than
perfection i know that i focus in a note
uh i know that something comes up that
that takes me away from what i'm
listening to but i also am well aware
that every so often i notice something
when i'm listening and uh of course
there's two types of listing in a way
there's the listening that i do of the
mini stories where it's kind of like an
exercise in trying to improve and trying
to remember as opposed to when i get you
know further enough along in the
language i'm listening because i'm
interested intrinsically interested in
what i'm listening to but even there
there are parts that i don't understand
so again i accept the fact that the
listening is going to have parts that i
don't understand
there are parts there are times when i
lose focus and yet still it's a learning
activity that i am able to do
while doing other tax tasks so if i have
to uh you know peel potatoes yeah i
don't mind i can stand there and peel
potatoes because i am slowly learning
uh
you know the language
so how do you really learn vocabs i mean
to me it's it's
entirely the process that we have at
link okay i read i listen i do a bit of
reviewing when i turn the page in the
lesson
and i just continue doing that and
gradually gradually gradually
uh it it sinks in anki okay that's
uh
you know some people like anki i'm not a
fan i don't like spending i i have so
many words that i'm learning all the
time if i had to go through them all on
anki it would be rather uninteresting i
prefer to encounter those words
in whatever order they appear
in the content that i'm listening to and
reading
you know people have asked me before
about pewdiepie or something i have no
idea what that is and i'm so busy with
what i'm doing i'm not about to get
involved
do you guys have any tips for a japanese
learner again eric might want to comment
because he is a japanese learner
i learned japanese a long long time ago
i was in japan but again the method was
a lot of listening and reading obviously
long before link but i listened to
content over and over and over again
did as much reading as i could but i had
a
big advantage
and that i already knew the chinese
characters
all right
all right
james
okay let me have it on any thank you for
the pressure
okay now a lot of these are not intended
towards me
so i'll just hi steve watson another fan
does link
link teaches the students like italki
okay uh we do have
uh tutors
you find them at the uh tutor section
here uh i see that my i'm still sharing
my screen so if you go to the tutor area
here
and uh here we have oh i see there's a
new tutor there
uh here we have our tutors and you can
connect with them and book them i use
tutors from link both in arabic and in
persian
okay uh here we have a huge problem with
collocations
again you're getting too technical
i wish no one had invented the term
collocations
uh
you just get more and more used to the
language and you will gradually start
using natural phrases and when you're if
you are learning with link then you
should save phrases and you start to get
a sense of how these words are used i i
i kind of feel that a lot of these
technical terms
uh are not helpful because people then
become self-conscious geez am i using
collocations correctly
forget it just get used to the language
and you'll gradually speak more and more
naturally
okay hello steve from moscow hello
rudolph sergei
moscow got had a great time there
my uh you know the one problem with
learning
more and more languages
is that you don't have enough time to
spend with the languages that you
previously were in love with and that
are still there waiting to you know look
you're waiting to hook up with them
again i will hook up again with my
russian
okay well that's absolutely opened my
eyes with infrastructure what do you
read without audio when do you read
without audio when starting a new piece
uh i'm assuming this uh is directed
towards me
so a new piece i will typically
it varies sometimes i read it first i
like to i guess most of the time i
listen first
uh just to get some momentum
for the piece but if i don't have that
opportunity
then i read
and after having read it then i
definitely want to listen to it because
i find i need both in order to remember
anything if i'm having a conversation
with my tutor and she tells me the word
for something is this
there's no way i can remember it i can't
even repeat that two minutes later
uh so zero ability to remember anything
that that i'm told in a conversation but
if i get it when i get my tutor's report
hear a link i get a report with we'll
have that word in it i can read it i can
review it i can listen to it a few times
i listen the teacher records my uh my
list of words and phrases then i have a
chance so it's a combination of both and
and i haven't found
uh
i haven't found
that it matters what you do
you just do whatever you feel like doing
if you're like listening you listen if
you like reading you read you feel like
reading and listening at the same time i
sometimes do that i think you want to
mix it up i think in language learning
variety is good okay
and number two you really have entered
anyone over there people ask god to say
it's a joke
any new language is coming
again new languages
you know where of two mice we get asked
to you know add languages and the
reality is that not many people study
those languages so we recently added
gujarati and we added bulgarian we add
languages because people provide us with
let's say the mini stories translated
so if we get if we have if someone has
put the effort into creating content
that is audio and transcript for those
languages we will add them but
realistically not a lot of people study
them
okay hi from algeria well i was next
door in morocco had a great time
uh blah blah blah i would like to visit
algeria one day and what do you think
about that tell us something about okay
okay i think i need some motivation
okay
so i think a lot of people are talking
with each other let me get out of
there's no particular
issue that you would like to have me
address i will stop my share screen stop
uh and i'm back here
okay that's it i don't know that there's
anything else people want to raise
uh so thank you
i'm gonna get back to studying my uh
persian
and uh thank you for
participating bye for now